hey everybody my name is joel courtney
and i'm megan young and i'm joey king we
are the cast of the kissing booth 3 and
we are here with buzzfeed to play a game
of who's who
numero uno who is most likely to give
relationship advice
my personal feeling is it's
is it's megan and myself i was gonna say
that too i mean i've come to you a lot
and i feel like
i'm also very opinionated as well
i would agree actually you too i
struggle like putting like
my words into like positive advice i am
a good listener you are a very good
listener that's true but turning it
around into action i struggle with that
department we all have our strengths man
don't beat yourself up who's most likely
to be caught napping in between scenes
joey
i don't even have to think about it you
know how many photos i have of you
sleeping and like
like i mean joel you're like a close
like second like super close thank you
really like the best feeling is just to
be like all right guys chatty chatty
all right look it's such a
little cat naps
it's a gift it is a gift it is a gift i
was envious of you because i couldn't
nap i couldn't do that and i'd be like
really tired and watching you just like
snoring in the corner number three who's
the best at doing impressions of other
cast members i wouldn't say joey i think
yeah
i am definitely going for it i don't
know if it's that i'm the best at it or
if it's that i just obnoxiously do it
all the time
that could definitely be it number four
who is most like their character joel
i kind of think so too i would
definitely agree with that yeah no i
also think i'm kind of like my character
like i feel like rachel and i are pretty
similar but i would also say
you are but you're more of an onion than
rachel you know
megan young you just got to peel back
those layers and then yeah okay so joel
it's just shallow
yet joel you're so yellow
i'm a one level onion over here okay
who's least like their character okay i
actually might need help with this
because i always feel like this whole
see like whole show was cast perfectly
francis who plays vivian aka british oh
you are yes right about this she plays
that character so perfectly but when you
get to know her you're like
oh
okay
yeah yeah she's like a total goofball
and like so like quirky and weird and in
a in the best way that is the perfect
answer
and
trent
also trent yes i remember the first time
we saw trent's lion tattoo like this
chest piece and we're all like
yo true that is badass like what you
can't show that on camera because it
immediately makes him like the coolest
person in school who's most likely to
tell their crush they like them
cool that's all
both of us got into the relationships
we're in now exactly that's true
you i like you joel i actually watched i
watched your like telling of your story
with mia and about how you went on that
hike and you were like you just answered
people that you ran into and you're like
yeah we're dating and she was like so
that's why i thought you i was like this
is like he's the one to be like yep i
like you i want you you're mine
thank you very soon very sweet who's
most likely to kick ass in the game of
dance dance revolution
absolutely joey i'm going to sign a wild
card here just because we haven't seen a
lot of it and i'd really like to see it
i'm going to say megan because i'd
really like to see megan hit that ddr
machine do you not remember from the
first can you get back in the first
movie like i did
that was like the one moment i was not
acting i was that yeah joel is a witness
because we did our like practice
together and
joel you know i wasn't good there was
there's no way it's not me no i will say
joey and i had hours of practice and
then you came in they were like okay do
this now go film it and there was no
time to like excel at it
uh but yeah you did not excel at that no
i didn't
i didn't know
it was perfect who's most likely to cry
on the last day of filming we were all
crying last day that was tough who's the
most likely to always always always be
happy for their besties success
not me
are you about to say the same thing it's
gonna be like i don't like these guys i
don't want them to be successful
you guys
don't support any of these people
honestly like the entire the entire
ensemble was just so like an incredibly
like tight-knit and just had such an
amazing time on set
there's no there's no answer i mean
pick anybody off the call sheet and you
would have a getting there's no answer
because everyone hates each other
i'm happy for everything they do and i
know that i can call them at any time
and never feel like i'm bragging always
just feel like i can celebrate with them
and that's such a good thank you so much
for having us buzzfeed yeah thank you so
much this is so fun and make sure you
check us out on netflix august 11th
kissing booth three
[Music]
you